Everything you’ve ever known is a lie! At
least, when it comes to superhero films. Maybe.
It's time to put the Justice League and Avengers
on the sidelines as we speculate on some crazy
superhero film theories that could just change...everything.
Stan Lee is the Watcher
You probably thought Stan Lee was making cameos
in every Marvel film just because he’s awesome,
but there might be another reason: maybe he's
actually playing the role of Uatu the Watcher.
Who? Well, the Watcher is a cosmic being tasked
with cataloguing what happens on Earth without
interfering. He watches everything from the
background—exactly like Stan Lee. Could
Stan really be an extraterrestrial voyeur?
It explains everything.
Wonder Woman and Aquaman are Kryptonian
Remember in Man of Steel when Clark Kent found
a crashed Kryptonian scout ship on Earth?
The ship had been sitting in ice for over
18,000 years, which begs the question: what
happened to the Kryptonians on that ship?
Well, some fans think they survived and used
their tech to establish an underwater colony
which eventually became Aquaman's home of
Atlantis. Others suggest they founded Wonder
Woman’s Amazonian society of Themyscira.
Or both!
Making them all Kryptonian sounds weird, but
it would at least explain where all these
super people come from.
Jared Leto's Joker is Jason Todd
Stop us if you’ve heard this one, but there
are some people who think Jared Leto’s version
of The Joker from Suicide Squad...is actually
Batman’s former sidekick, Robin.
"Holy Benedict Arnold!"
In Batman v Superman, Bruce Wayne's Batcave
had a memorial set up for what was presumably
the last Robin, Jason Todd. In the comics,
the Joker severely beats Todd with a crowbar,
before killing him in an explosion. He was
brought back from the grave, went nuts, and—as
twisted tribute to his attacker—took up
The Joker’s previous costumed identity,
The Red Hood.
What if Leto's Joker is actually a crazed
Jason Todd, taking up the mantle of the villain
who ruined his life? While director Zack Snyder
has said in interviews that Robin was, indeed,
killed by the Joker, he may be trying to redirect
fans from a big reveal. Now that would be
a really good joke...
(Joker laughing hysterically)
We met Star-Lord's dad in Guardians of the
Galaxy
One of the biggest dangling plot threads in
Guardians of the Galaxy is the identity of
Peter "Star-Lord" Quill's father. But what
if he was in the movie after all?
We know Quill's father's an alien, and that
Star-Lord has the ability to use an Infinity
Stone without exploding, which is kind of
a big deal.
Who else can do that? Adam Warlock, a weird
space-hippie who hatched from a cocoon—which
appeared to be part of The Collector’s display.
Did it contain Star-Lord’s dad? We won’t
know until the sequel.
The Red Skull still lives
The last time we saw the Red Skull, the HYDRA
leader was fighting Captain America for control
of the Tesseract. The Skull grabbed it, only
to have a portal open and suck him in, apparently
wiping him out of existence.
So where did the Red Skull go? Since the Tesseract
is capable of anything, there’s no end to
the shenanigans he could be up to. Wherever
he ended up, our money is on the Red Skull
to survive—and eventually return to the
Marvel Universe, stronger than ever before.
Cut off one limb and all that, right?
"Hail Hydra."
Thanks for watching! Subscribe to our YouTube
channel to watch more videos like the one
you just saw. And leave a comment to let us
know which superhero movie theories should've
made the list...